- Hi everyone, this is Jeremy
Schieffelin with Khan Academy.
Happy Friday.
We've now officially made it through
not only the full week, but
a full month of all of this.
So please give yourself
a huge pat on the back,
for surviving and progressing
in the face of everything going on.
Vladimir, same to you as well.
And a special thank you
actually to Vladimir here,
who was one of our All-star
Khan Academy Ambassadors.
So he has an AP Bio, excuse me,
AP Chemistry and AP Physics teacher,
based in West Palm Beach, Florida.
Even though he roots
for the Miami Dolphins
and I'm a Buffalo Bills fan,
I am still getting
Vladimir a mad love today,
because he is taking time
away from his own students
to make sure that you have everything
you need to serve yours.
And so as you know, if you've
joined previous webinars,
you can ask Vladimir
questions at any point,
by typing into the questions feature
of the GoToWebinar Control Panel
and after we sort of talked through
some of the basic stuff of Khan Academy,
Vladimir we'll take your questions live,
you'll actually be able to see on the site
how he works his magic, how
he gets the students engaged
with chemistry and physics
using Khan Academy.
So just let's start there Vladimir,
tell us a little about your
background as an educator
and then how you got
started with Khan Academy.
- This is my 21st year of teaching
and I teach mostly AP Chem and AP Physics,
but I also do Honors
Chemistry and Honors Physics.
And from time to time I
teach mathematics too,
which is kind of nice, I liked that too.
I have been working with Khan Academy
I guess from the beginning.
And the reason why I started doing this is
when I finished my doctorate degree,
my doctorate degree is
in Educational Technology
and Instructional Design.
So I kind of saw that
this was where the future
was going for us in education,
I'll try to be concise.
And so matter of fact, back in 2000, 2001,
when I worked for Palm
Beach County schools,
we created a clearing house
of materials free for all science teachers
and we actually began training teachers
in science and mathematics to use
the tools that we have
just given at the moment,
which is very good.
Back then it was just
kinda the beginning stuff
of using PowerPoint in the classroom
and using some tools in order to enhance,
the teaching of science and mathematics.
It was an easy transition
for us in science,
because we had a lot of videos
and a lot of different
things that we could do,
that will have a visual representation
of what we do in science.
Because sometimes it's incredibly complex
to show for temple, let's say
for example, a picture of
an atom and people question,
"How in the world do you see an atom?
"How do we know that it exists that way?"
But then we can show mathematical models
and we can show 3D pictures,
and for the students to
grab a better understanding
of very abstract components
of science and mathematics
that we see from time to time.
So a biggest thing for a longer time.
- Very cool and you're
getting a little love here
from April, who says Miami Dolphins rule.
Whereas Janet says, she's
a New York Giants fans
so she has no judgment.
Even though they tore our
hearts apart in Super Bowl 25,
but hey, that's ancient history now.
Okay so that being said,
let's cut to the chase here.
I think folks right now
are hurting in the sense
that every educator in this country,
every educator in this world frankly,
is being forced to do things
that they were not trained
to do in most cases.
When it comes to remote
learning, using tools like this.
If you were just getting started today,
if you didn't have the advantage
of a track record with Khan Academy,
what would you do, if
you were trying to serve
your science students
tomorrow or on Monday
using a tool like Khan Academy?
How would you start?
- The way that I will begin is,
obviously there's a wealth of information
that we can find online.
Especially when we need something
that shows results and
that is clearly delineated
and that it is already
broken down by subject,
not only by subject but also by topic.
And that it has resources,
that also has a wonderful
program with the community
where you can ask questions,
and there are a number of
people who are involved
and who can answer any of your questions.
What I would do is, I would
begin just showing my students
just a basic understanding
and creating a classroom
in Khan Academy where
my students can log on.
Because it is a wonderful
compliment to any classroom.
I've been using it for a long time
and I use it in my AP
courses all the time.
And is just being really a...
It really is a game changer
and the fact that we can deliver
a location at any point and time,
where we can create courses
and we can create even assignment
where the students can
go at their own pace.
You can integrate into
any of your courses,
because it perfectly aligns with
whatever it is that you're looking for.
To me it's the best
resource that I've used.
That's why I got really excited about it
and I wanted to know more
and I wanted to pass
it on to other people.
I have trained all of the
science department in my school
and the use of Khan Academy
and everyone is already using it to assign
to create courses, just to
use that as a compliment
for class, especially for AP courses.
It's just unbelievable,
it really is amazing.
- Cool so, I've shared
that community resource
with everyone in the Chat.
So if they want to talk to
other Khan Academy Ambassadors,
like Latimer, they can do
that through that group.
As far as talking to your students,
it sounds like what you're saying is,
you might actually do a Zoom meeting
or Google Hangout meeting
with your students now.
And actually just pull this
up on your screen and say,
"Hey, here's Khan Academy,
"here's what an exercise looks like."
And that way they can see it,
before you ask them to do
anything, is that right?
- Right, well yes I'm sorry,
I kinda went a little further.
I'm coming to thinking of myself
and the way that I done it.
But you're exactly correct
and that is what I have
pulled my teachers through,
the teacher that I've trained to do it.
The first thing you have to do is
you have to go with
your students very easy,
maybe two or three days,
where they can have
a basic understanding of the navigation
and all the things that are
available in Khan Academy.
But if you can set up
a Google Hangout meet,
actually I think it's called Google...
They changed the name I believe.
- Yeah, Google meet or whatever, yeah.
- Or assume, for example,
if you can use that
and go step by step and
showing your students
how to sign up, how to find the resources,
where the assignments
are going to be located.
But it's actually pretty intuitive to use.
Once my teachers have used
it for two or three times,
they say, "Oh, I'm old."
Some of my students
would probably get it in
one or two tries and then it
becomes a wonderful resource.
Once they begin using it more and more,
the more proficient you become at it
and the easier it is
going to be to integrate
into your own classes.
- Very cool and so, maybe
you show them an exercise,
which you can always find just
by searching at the very top.
So just like I did, I went
up to courses and I said,
"Show me the AP Physics content
or the AP Chemistry content."
You can obviously search
for anything in particular,
so if you want to do Thermodynamics,
knock yourself out, right?
- Right, absolutely.
- In terms of sort of getting students
up to speed about the exercises,
'cause in some ways that's
the heart of Khan Academy.
How do you recommend
that they tackle this?
Do you say, "Hey, just go
through it and do it once."
Do you tell them to use
hands or watch videos,
how is your students think about this?
- Well that's kind of
interesting question,
because I use it in a number of ways.
And one way that I found
very effective a couple of,
maybe about a year ago
or so is that again,
now it's a little more
complicated to do it
because we're in a virtual environment.
But I had tried it already
and it actually works
the same way that it will
work in the classroom.
And soon you can create small groups.
Again, I haven't used
a Google Meet too much,
but I have done it in Zoom
where for example, I assigned eight people
that has already preloaded
into my Google classroom assignments
and my students will work to access that.
And what I do is actually,
I watched the video on Khan Academy first
and I get the exact same
question that they have used,
and I used that question
on just a Word document.
What I do is I create the
actual video link, as a QR code
and once they begin
answering the questions,
then we all do a question
first in different groups,
and then we all come together again
and we discuss the question
and when I ask them to do
after they have actually
completed the question, then
we click on the QR code,
either do it on their phones
or they do it straight on their computer.
And then we can see how the
question's actually done
and then we talk about it
and we compare the answers.
And my students really,
really liked that exercise
because again it's a lot of
confidence, once they say,
"Oh really, I can do this,
"or oh, this is what I went wrong.
"Maybe I need to go back
and review what I did
"to make my corrections."
So it works really,
really well in that sense.
- And just to give folks
a sense of what's possible
in addition to the videos,
if you wanna actually
look at some of those exercises together,
you can come into your classroom.
So let's say you've
created a biology classroom
or a chemistry classroom,
you're coming to your assignment section
and your score section, and
you could actually look at
those student answers as a class and say,
"Hey, I noticed that half the class
"got the wrong answer here,
let's talk about that."
So I bought the mistaken
assumptions behind that
and really tackle it as a class
as opposed to you're
on your own, good luck.
(cross talking)
That's a fair way of explaining, yeah.
- Yes, absolutely 100% correct.
Not only that, but I also like
the fact that you can go
into any of the assignments
that you have given to your courses.
And you can pick any individual
student and you can see,
for example, if I sign up
one of my students, they say,
"Oh Dr. V, I already know this question.
"So what I'm going to do is,
"I'm just going to watch the videos."
I say, "Look, whatever
you feel comfortable with,
"I'm going to be okay with
that, but what I want to see
"is I want to see that you have
actually watched the videos,
"because that is how I am going to be sure
"that you have actually watched them."
And it gives me statistics on the time
that they have watched the video.
So if a student tells me,
"Yeah, I've watch the video."
And I said, "No, you actually
only watched about 15 seconds
"of the video, that doesn't equate."
"Okay, I'll watch it."
So it's a good way to
also hold them accountable
for what they say they are doing.
So it's a wonderful resource, correct.
- Absolutely, I'll just call out that.
In addition to scoring the exercises,
you can ask you to tell on your end
whether students have read the
articles and watch the videos
by looking at their green check
under those kinds of assignments.
- Absolutely, and that
could even be an assignment
on its own right to, which I have done
with my classes as well.
I'd say once I see all
the green check marks,
then I know that you have
completed all of your assignments
you need to do, so you're
going to get full credit
for that assignment, if not
then we have to go back and do it.
And the good thing about it is
like for the quizzes they...
The other part that I like about is that
they self adjust.
They are going to go with what
their student is answering
and they have multiple times too.
You can actually set it up that way
to answer multiple times,
instead of just one time,
to give them a chance, so
they can revise the question
or review the question and then
go back and answer it again.
- Yeah, so do you think
that like ultimately
the goal of Khan Academy,
is not just to be an assessment tool,
but to be a mastery driving tool,
where we encourage students
to have those multiple temps
and actually keep pushing themselves
to really understand it at a deep level,
not just the motions.
- Absolutely, absolutely 100%.
I agree with that statement a
hundred percent on that, yes.
- Cool, okay any other advice
you wanna give teachers at this point
or should we head into the
questions from the audience?
- I think we can take
questions from the audience.
I don't wanna take all
the time explaining.
I think, it would be
better if we just answer
what their needs are
going to be at the moment,
because I know that we have
a number of people you say
are going to be on there right now,
or on there right now.
- Yeah, we have about
230 science educators
across the country, so
no pressure Vladimir.
But Sandy says, "Thank
you for all that you do.
"You are amazing, so thanks
for making this possible."
Similar love from April,
even as a Dolphin'S fan.
And let's talk through
some of the questions
that are coming in here.
Okay so, okay, this is interesting.
So you're gonna get a
question that basically says,
we've talked a lot about AP
and like really making
good progress and all that.
If you have a special education
student in your classroom,
is there any way to
differentiate using Khan Academy?
Is there any way to make sure that
every student is getting what they need
not just sort of lock
step for the entire class?
- Absolutely, 100%.
Because, Khan Academy is not only for...
It's known to sign only for
the higher level courses.
It has every single level
that you can imagine.
It has from the basic
levels all the way to
a very high level AP
and if you can access just
any course that you want
also by grade.
Oh, it's on the screen right now.
You can access by grade, but
you can access it at any level.
And the good thing about it too, again,
is remember you can make it,
so it's a self-phase guide
that the students can follow
and in their own time or
in their own timeframe,
whatever that needs to be
at the moment right now,
I think we're all in survival mode
and we're all concentrating
on more on the learning
than in the actual assessment piece.
But that's where we are right now.
So it serves any student at any
level, absolutely 100%, yes.
- Cool and then just
sort of build upon that,
if you said, "Hey."
I noticed that I have a
student, no matter what their
sort of situation is, who needs to go back
and sort of fill in some
gaps from over in the year,
this could actually be a
nice opportunity to do that.
And you can actually make assignments
of specific pieces of content,
not just to your whole class
but to individual students
who really need that support.
- Correct, absolutely.
- Okay, so here's a related
question from April.
April wants to know, how
you do your Pasic, Vladimir.
Terms of all these
videos, articles, quizzes.
Are you willing them out,
several at a time, one a day?
What's your cadence?
- It depends on the course again,
because I teach from regular
levels all the way to AP.
In my regular level
courses and honors courses,
what I do is I do maybe
two or three at a time,
that they can watch.
And depends also on the
length of the video time,
some of them are anywhere between seven
and 60 minutes of play.
So what are times only
maybe one or two a day,
because you have to be mindful to that,
their home, it's a completely
different situation right now
and we want to follow our class,
because we all believe that our classes
are the most important classes, right?
But we have to be mindful
that they have other classes
that they also have to
meet with other teachers
and not everyone is going
to have the same level
of comfort using the
technology as of right now.
And you probably are going
through that right now
experiencing the same, am
I doing this correctly?
And the answer is, yes you are
because nobody really
has a definite guideline
on how this is going to be
maybe a net in a month or so.
And we'll probably will
be in this situation
for until the end of the year.
So they said any way that you wish,
but be mindful again, that
they are going to be also
having other classes and
that might be a factor
on how you space out are a little more.
Again, I'm coming context.
The first thing that I
did, when I found out
that I was going to be teaching online.
I said, "Okay, let me
see what is essential
to me right now."
So I went back into my
curriculum and I said,
"I can leave this out,
I can leave this out,
I can leave this out.
Because the thing is
that also the AP census
a shortened version of what the content
was going to be for the fan.
And I had already finished
covering everything
so that was a good thing.
For my other courses, I just went with
the most necessary
things that I need to do,
so that they at least
can continue to science.
So you're gonna have to
make that decision yourself
depending on your experience
and also depending on what it is
that you want to cover
throughout the year.
- Great and one piece of advice I've heard
from a lot of Ambassadors
in these webinars,
is just go slow at first.
Don't try to like, come out of the barn
racing 60 miles an hour,
give yourself that time
to build that foundation,
the same we'd recommend for your students.
- Correct.
Another question, Katrina,
there's actually a really
appropriate for this screen,
is are the lessons on Khan Academy aligned
with the NGSS standards?
- Yes.
Yes they can be.
They can be, but for the most part
they do align.
- Absolutely.
- Absolutely 100%, and I know that
because I actually went
through the alignment process
when I did my courses.
I wanted to make sure that
everything I was covering
was actually quoted on
that, but a hundred percent
- Yeah, I'll give you a
little sort of pro tip here.
Not only does it have
these sort of citations
throughout the lessons,
but you can actually search by standard.
So if you knew the exact
standard you needed,
you'd come up here, you'd paste it in,
and then voila, you've got
the exact piece of content
that's aligned with that too.
- Right.
- All right, great question.
(cross talk)
Ooh wow, okay, here is a
really tough question for you.
So Peter is saying, "I work
with what are typically called
"at-risk students, who
are sometimes difficult
"to engage in the classroom,
let alone from a distance."
With distance, every
challenge is magnified
and he's being really honest with us.
He's like, I often use food as
a hook, just the way to say,
"Hey, come to my class and gauge.
"What is the best way to draw my students,
"giving that I no longer have
that in-person relationship
"to build upon.
"How do I keep them motivated
at a moment like this?
- That is a really, really
tough question to answer.
Again, just because we're
lacking that personal touch
and that proximity and that
connection that we did,
there is no way that we can
make the human connection
through a computer.
I know we try our best
and I know that this is what
we have been forced to do.
Okay, this is no one's choice.
But the way that I would say it is,
it's just keep asking your students,
keep the motivation, keep the faith.
At the end of the day,
at least in my 21 years of experience,
I know that if I put my heart
and soul into these things,
my students are going to appreciate it
and they are going to follow it.
You have to show them that
you love the subject, okay?
And that you care about them
and that you appreciate what they do.
And your students are going
to care about your class,
once they know how much
you care about them
and about their future and about their...
And I know and I'm probably
sounding very idealistic
and dreamy right now, but you know what
that's just the way that
I would approach it.
I will put my heart into it and just say,
"Look guys, we're gonna
have to have do this.
"Okay, this is just the
way that it is going to do
"and this is going to be important."
Just to emphasize that this is going
to be part of their future.
That this is just the way
that things are going to be right now.
This is not always going to be the case,
but just to keep going
at it and to have faith
and that's a difficult piece.
Just to bring the
motivation factor into it.
Again, because we're not in the classroom
and in my classroom, I'm very animated,
I'm very high energy
and that is the same projection
that I try to bring to the screen, okay?
I tried to make it that we
have to do this for them
and it is about them, number one.
- Yeah I actually don't think
that's idealistic at all.
I think that's incredibly practical
giving the world we're in.
To like lose hope and to
sort of throw up our hands
as educators, is to ultimately drag us
and the whole classroom
down, we have to say strong.
I will give a very
practical piece of advice
that I've heard from other ambassadors,
is just keep the lines
of communication open.
And I know that it's doubly
hard with at-risk students,
because of maybe a lack of
technological resources,
but if you've access to texts or remind
or ClassDojo or just whatever it is,
if you can let them know that
you're thinking about them
and you care about them and
you want to keep serving them.
I think that reminds them that
hey, they've got someone in
their corner of the ring,
and that's all every
student craze right now.
- Right.
- Cool, okay amazing advice.
Here's a really important
question from Kathy,
'cause it speaks to the
reality that a lot of teachers
are going through right now.
I know educators want to go online,
they wanna do things like Zoom
or Google Meetings or whatever,
but a lot of districts
are actually forbidding it
in the name of equity saying,
"Hey, until we can serve
all of our students,
"we just can't be doing live instruction."
If Kathy is teaching in
a district like that,
what kind of advice
would you give as far as
how do you roll this out?
Is even realistic to roll it out,
if you can't do a live walkthrough,
if all you could do is like, send an email
or give a handout that said,
"Hey, go to khanacademy.org
and do this lesson,
would that be enough?
- I find that very difficult
and it's kind of interest
that you mentioned that
because I actually had a
phone call with a friend
about a week ago, and his
school district actually said,
because of the inequality that we have,
number one in technology and number two
in just providing the resources
that we need for the entire County.
The County decided actually
to shut down the schools,
because if it's not going
to be equitable for everyone
then we cannot do it.
And I guess they...
In my understanding is that,
that came from the legal
team of the County.
And in that sense, I really
do not have an answer.
Can you assign work that they can do
on Khan Academy to continue?
Absolutely 100%.
Because I do that every year.
I'll say, "Guys, if you want to go ahead,
"this is what I will suggest."
Because I have a lot of my students
who are very interested in continuing
and they say, "Hey,
what do we do after AP?
Maybe you could continue and do research
or maybe you wanna look into it.
Okay and maybe you want to continue
and do your own self-paced course.
But other than that, that
is pretty tough question
because most of the time,
at least in my understanding
that came from a legal team saying,
"We cannot provide it
because it's not going to be
"equitable for everyone."
And again, right now with the
problem of the digital divide
is a hundred times amplified.
Even in my County, which
is a pretty wealthy County
in Florida, we're seeing
the differences right now
among the kids who have the technology
and those who don't have it.
Those who have maybe one computer at home
and also need to share one computer
among five, six brothers at home
and their brothers and sisters.
So it's a complicated topic.
- Yeah, and I'll just give
one very quick work around.
If you're not able to walk
them through registration
and giving assignments and all that,
one thing you can do to
keep it really simple,
is you can literally
just send out the URLs
for any piece of content on Khan Academy.
- Yeah.
- So for example, if you want
people to watch this video
about human body systems,
we'll do this exercise about cells,
you'll notice in a very top address bar,
there's a unique URL that
you could copy and paste
into an email, into a text
message, into a remind app.
And that way, even if you can't walk them
through the full experience,
you can get your students
working on something in the meantime.
You're not gonna have tracking,
you're not gonna have
to look all the reports
that we talked about, but
at least it fills that void
and get them learning in
this sort of period of limbo.
- Right.
- Here is a really amazing
and inspiring question from Sandy.
So Sandy says, "Vladimir,
I'm working with 160
"middle school students on a
Pine Ridge Indian Reservation.
"Talent is distributed evenly,
but opportunity is not.
"How can I help the students
that are now remote,
"to engage in more hands-on activities
"with things they can easily
find in their household."
And for example, she teaches math,
but she want it once to integrate
with the whole steam spectrum.
So makerspace, robotics, flight
simulations, snap circuits,
how can she bring that
same hands-on learning
sense of excitement and
engagement, but do it virtually?
- Well, that's a pretty
interesting question
because I am actually wondering myself,
how am I going to do
some of the basic things
that I have done with
my classes typically?
But now that they're home
and I don't know if they have
the materials that they need to do it.
And again, I cannot require them to go
and buy anything right now,
that would not be fair for them.
I say, "Hey, go and find what you need."
Because I don't wanna put anybody at risk
of compacting anything, or
be in contact with anyone
who might be infected.
But, that is a pretty tough question.
Can I defer that one to you Jeremy?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I was gonna say that,
I have been really inspired
teaching my own kids,
with the number of resources out there,
way beyond Khan Academy.
They have super simple like
do yourself home experiment.
So for example, this is super simple,
it's for elementary school,
but my daughter just dissolve
the outside layer of an egg using vinegar.
- Right.
- This was like the most
mind-blowing moment for them,
even though it was just two things that
I'm hopeful we all have in our house.
I don't know about the eggs anymore
giving the egg shortage,
but at least the vinegar.
And so hopefully that
gives you a sense Sandy,
that if you just check out
what's out there on the Web,
I guarantee you're gonna
find lots of other nonprofits
just like Khan Academy,
that are in the STEM space
that are offering resources like that.
And I would encourage you to discover them
and then also share them in
the Khan Academy community,
'cause I know there are other educators
who are in the same boat.
- Right, and I guess I found that one
a little hard to answer because again,
I don't work with the little ones.
And for example, for my students,
I use a lot of simulations that are online
that are wonderful,
like the PhET Colorado.
That is a wonderful resource that has
tons of different demonstrations
from physics, chemistry, biology.
But again, it's a little more advanced
geared towards the high school,
college level type of students.
- Great, okay so Elaine is gonna ask
a really good advocate question.
So we were talking before about this idea
of doing multiple rounds on exercise.
So you take a first
version of the exercise,
maybe you only score 50%, but you say,
"I'm gonna push for mastery."
So I do it again, this time I get 90%
I'm in that mastery range.
Elaine wants to know, how do you know
they aren't just memorizing the answers
to get a better score versus
actually achieving mastery?
- Well you know what, and we have wrestled
with that question for a long, long time.
Even before this, because
I had that question
many times before.
And the other third
question is going to be that
as long as they've reached a mastery level
and they are memorizing the questions,
then I'm okay with that,
because it is about exposure.
At the end of the day, this is not
the ultimate determination of their grade
or the ultimate determination
of the knowledge
that they are going to
have but I tell them too,
"Guys, you need to go
through this exercise,
you need to do it in honest
and you need to do it.
Because at the end of the day,
this might fall into intellectual suicide
if you don't do it.
You might be thinking,
"Yes, I'm going to do it
"because I'm going to copy the answer,
"so I'm just going to ask my friend
"what is the correct answer."
But when it comes to answering the test,
that's where you're going to prove to me
that you either did it
or you didn't do it.
And a lot of times the students are going
to be pretty receptive to that bonus
but this is for your own benefit
and this is the reason
why we're doing this.
So whether they do it and
they go over again and say,
"Oh, this is the answer to the question."
At least they know what the correct answer
to the question is going to be.
So they are being exposed
to what the correct answer
and the correct procedure or
whatever the question may be.
So that's why we have to
have just a little bit of,
I would say trust in that
they are doing it correctly.
Now, is this going to be done
with a 100% of the times?
No, but most of them are
actually going to do it
in an honest way, in
my experience at least.
- Very cool and I will also mention that
Khan Academy is not just showing the same
four questions over and over again,
for every single exercise it's
drawing from a question bank.
So yes, the student
could memorize the answer
and all 12 questions going
through the multiple rounds,
but you'll see that they
did it seven or eight times,
which will probably be a
tip off of what's happening.
So definitely take
advantage of the breadth
and depth of the content,
as well as just that first iteration.
That being said, I know
we're almost at time here,
so for the folks who
didn't have their questions
answered today, what other
resources would you recommend
for getting support?
It sounded like the Khan
Academy community was important.
Anything else that you would turn
to get advice or expertise from Khan?
- The community is a
great resource obviously
that the website it's a great resource.
And it's just a number of things
that you actually can do, an
introduction to new material
that's the way that I've
used it from time to time.
I tell my students, if you
guys are going to start
for example, Thermodynamics
and I want you to watch
these two videos before you come to class,
because I am going to
begin with a discussion of
why heat flows the way it flows.
You can use it to compliment anything
that you're having in your
classes, again as resources.
Remember the ability to
integrate into any course too,
it's just a wealth of information.
As a matter of fact, you're
gonna have to cut down
on some of the information,
because it was so extensive
that it could be overwhelming
if it's the first time
that you see it, and
maybe some of the things
might not be appropriate for your classes.
It is wonderful to use
this for assignment,
some assignment tool, a practice guide,
getting ahead, you name it.
Also the SAT Program that
a lot of people know about.
I have people who I have trained
in Khan Academy and I said,
"Wow, I didn't know that they had
"an SAT program they can fall in."
And actually I assign this to my students,
as an assignment, I said,
"You guys have to
complete it once a week."
You have to show up and I do
a weekly assignment on SAT,
and at the end of the year
they're just thrilled about,
"Wow, thank you for
giving us that resource
"because it was just
a wonderful resource."
But these are just some of the
ways in which I have utilized
and I'm sure that many other ambassadors
and many other people have used
it, they have many different
ways of using it.
But again, every time that
I have a question that I
do not know how to
answer it, I immediately
go to the community resources
and I type the question
and the number of answers
I get, it's just wonderful.
It's very helpful and people
will answer your questions.
It's just a great regrade resource.
- Very cool, I think that's
actually a perfect note
to end on, which is not only is there this
amazing community out there,
but there are folks like Vladimir,
who are sharing their own expertise
and paying it forward to the
next generation of Econ tutors.
So Vladimir, thank you so
much for doing exactly that
for our entire audience
of science educators say--
- Thank you for having me.
- Thank you to everyone out there
for investing time in today's session.
I know it's been a long
week, it's been a long month,
I know there's a long road ahead,
but we're getting there, we're
taking one step at a time
and the fact that you shared
this time with us today,
says a ton about your
commitment to your students
and serving them incredibly well.
So thank you for all that you do.
Thank you again Vladimir,
and here's wishing everyone a
peaceful and relaxing weekend.
Thank you so much.
- Jeremy, can I add one
more thing before we go?
Is there any way, because I
know I have people who tell me,
"Can you give us your
contact information?"
Is that even appropriate
to say this is my email,
if you have any questions you can email me
and I will try my best
to answer your questions
or would that be something that is not...
- Yeah, if you're comfortable,
I'd be happy to share that
in the follow-up email if that's okay.
- Sure, that would be great.
- Wonderful, well Vladimir
again has just gone above
and beyond, so if you have
questions directly about
AP Physics, AP Chemistry,
or anything else,
STEM related on Khan Academy.
Vladimir, you have totally done
an incredible service here.
So thank you again.
- Thank you.
- Thank you to everyone else out there.
Hope you have a wonderful weekend.
- Thank you, thank you too.
- Bye all.